I have a problem with Zynga the social
game publisher is doing something that
is positively insidious and I don't mean
creating interactive time sinks so
addictive that they could have been
designed by an evil behavioralist
mastermind bent on enslaving humanity my
problem was Zynga is excuse me I need to
harvest some corn my issue with Zynga is
the way they've turned their digital
games into analog tabletop games in
appropriate genre crossing first they
released a farmville branded version of
Hungry Hungry Hippos called Angry hungry
herd they were placed a hippo's with
farm animals but hey at least hungry
hungry herd is honest it's a new brand
slapped on top of a familiar game not
unlike Halo risk or Star Wars operation
it's crass but in a familiar almost
comforting sort of way but now singer
has criss cross between the physical
world and the digital world in ways the
ty reality into a Gordian knot it's
turned it's digital games words with
friends and draw something into board
games board games do I have to spell out
why this threatens to tear a hole in the
space-time continuum it's clear as day
that words with friends
owes a huge debt to Scrabble and draw
something shares a suspicious number of
features with pictionary so follow along
with me here we have two classic board
games reverse-engineered to become video
games and now these left-handed copies
are being transformed back into new
board games I think if you touch a
scrabble tile two awards with friends
style it opens a portal into a parallel
universe
but it's the shamelessness that really
gets me like no one's going to notice
that this new board game seems a little
bit familiar
hey Zynga I had a brainstorm why don't
you take your popular Facebook game
Texas Hold'em and turn it into a real
world card game I'm thinking a
collection of 52 pieces of cardboard
divided into four suits say 15
denominations players assemble special
groupings to win oh and why not sell
some zynga poker chips to I know how
much you love peddling virtual
currencies what's the longest single
stress you played a Zynga game for I
need to know right now in the comments
go there and subscribe to the wire
channel if you haven't already